today's topic
hey y'all hi
it's officially step daddy season
it's not an update
this is not an update
you didn't know it was officially
stepped daddy season well yeah cause
she's looking for stuff daddy round
number two actually you know what that's
an update
update
oh [ __ ] abba
step daddy season abba yeah you know
what what
i'm in l.a now
not new york anymore i was supposed to
live here in new york but i'm in l.a now
all right i'm chilling let's find out
what this step daddy sees if you guys
don't know what stepdaddy season is
think about like hot boy summer all
right or hot girl summer right this is
this whole thing about all right it's a
new wave for people right we we living
differently well now it's step daddy
summer all right step daddy season let's
find out what that means hey y'all hi
it's officially step daddy season
okay though your cat
yeah what up i got the
car seat in the back
let's go to the park
don't let your baby mama or your baby
daddy block your blessings
i know in theory it sounds good keeping
the same person have kids with
but that's insanity as well so if it
doesn't work out with them it'll work
out with someone else
it's absolutely insanity to
want a stable family and stay with the
person you had kids with i think i said
that before go ahead this functionality
is a norm now that's a normal yeah these
are these people are trying to normalize
[ __ ] that's not normal that's not normal
it's not normal for you to just casually
have kids with somebody like it'll work
out somebody else it's a big decision it
also has a huge impact on your child
these people are weird like i would
never see my dad call my mom his baby
mom there's people in couples called
that's my baby mom no
it's your wife
if it's not your wife that's your girl
[ __ ] you me yo babe i gotta admit i
can't stand people that are together and
just call themselves baby mama baby dad
no
oh he's more than that god damn it
ugh but you know what it's because they
grew up in so much dysfunction
that's the norm no no they create
language around it because you have to
imagine right if you're with a woman and
you have a child to someone who's
looking outside there's no guarantee
that that person is the mother of that
child right yeah so sometimes you gotta
specify which is already indication of a
larger issue
exactly i digress
okay
it just will that's how that goes and
trust me i know it's ghetto
that's how you know she got pretty
privileged
she just assumes
that
having a kid won't hamper some people's
dating yeah maybe for you because you
you considered a very attractive woman
right so it's constantly dudes but for a
lot of other people it's a struggle
having a child and trying to be out
there dating things is just gonna work
out for a lot of women and a lot of
dudes out there is not the case so you
know just you're interested in hearing
this because like it just will code word
for [ __ ] i'm hot that's what it is
it is so good at being a baby mama and
thinking about multiple baby daddies is
scary
but
you my baby gonna be all right
we're gonna be all right so we moving
forward onward upward okay i know a lot
of you are skeptical about talking to
people with children but i can assure
you
the baby mamas now today
we don't give a damn
you can have them i have
exited the rat race i am not a threat i
want you to be around for a long time
not a good time you can hold my son put
him on your story i trust his judgment i
really do i really really do i just want
you guys to be happy i swear i do what
are you talking about who's gonna post
the kid on the story
the stepfather
did i understand that correctly
bro oh this is nonsense it doesn't
matter what she says
now i'm not a threat but you know i
can't speak for the other other other
other hoes that you don't know about
you know maybe i'll definitely be in
your favor
but
i am here for it
okay like people move on
save the you should have got the ring
first
it wasn't gonna work out anyways it just
wasn't gonna work out i mean if you had
that much foresight to know was it going
to work out then why have the kid with
him
you out here talking about other hoes
you're the one who's talking about
coming up on a bag for an nba player
because they're stupid that's you yeah
but you are the other hoes yeah but
she's at home are you acting like
sanctimonious about you you're part of
that girl no but she's higher
because she got the bag her other hoe is
the whole that don't have a bag she
secured a bag so to her she's a higher
hoe because she's out the rat race she
already got her money exactly she
already got her money yeah stuck her to
the back i don't even believe that you
know i don't even believe the next video
i want to do
if we have to do another one on her
because i'm about done it's another
update i wish that pj washington
uh seeks custody of the kid
and then gets it because all these
videos she's posting out there is
evidence that she's a bad person and if
the the jews rules that other than that
i don't want to hear it it's just going
to be normal
i know i know i know how it works i
understand but that would be a update
i'm gonna be here celebrating if that
hitch happens why
why not pj washington ain't got no
[ __ ] right mind to raise a kitty
absolutely not my man can't even choose
a good partner absolutely not okay he's
not posting out there being traveling
he posted himself with other ig models
right after getting off with this one
listen let's be honest you got two
dysfunctional people out here posting
their lives on social media about how
[ __ ] up they are but i'm just going to
be laughing because that's how she's
going to secure the bag trying to get
other [ __ ] and i just got to
have the bag get swept away from her
that would be fun but i know that's not
going to happen but if it does
get out of stuff i can get out
um
in conclusion
step daddy season
big aura
big lumber
big follow through need only appliances
um
did you notice the floor ain't saying
much
it's a whole lot of holes up in this
[ __ ] hey man i wish i guess i had
something inside for the same just let
them help get that money get that money
more yeah yeah you're just looking at
dysfunction
that's dysfunction right there that's
problem that's the new normal it's like
people are much more comfortable having
babies than even talking about it people
were much more comfortable having kids
because we had a wedlock with people
that they know they won't probably be
able to be around then they are actually
committing to being with them and then
having a kid this is a very weird
bizarre set of circumstances
just
this function is normal this function is
a new normal imagine being that kid who
finds out that the only reason he was
born so his mom get on a phone oh this
kid is
let's get
my mom had me because she needed some
cheddar
i don't have much time there's nothing
to add bro you know
that's what i'm saying it's not an
update it's nothing to add
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh